[Music]
hi everyone
i'm steve brunton from the university of
washington and i've been looking forward
to making this video for
years today i'm going to talk about how
we can model
very complex fluid dynamics systems
using sparse non-linear modeling
techniques
from machine learning so this is one of
my
favorite topics and this is an area of
active active research in my lab
here at uw and in
2016 we published a paper where we could
build sparse non-linear models from data
of systems and we looked at this simple
laminar flow past
a cylinder this was our kind of a big
example
in our 2016 paper and so in this lecture
i'm going to tell you about what's
happened in the last five years
and some of the big strides we've made
in extending this to much more complex
uh fluid dynamic systems so uh
from one cylinder to this three cylinder
configuration that has more broad
band turbulence uh we're looking at
electro convection system so this
is a complex three-way coupled device
uh we're looking at cavity flows okay so
really really interesting rich dynamics
of this cavity flow
um all the way up to spherimac fusion
reactor simulations we can build these
sparse nonlinear models
uh turbulent wake flows with our
experimental collaborators in europe
so very very excited to walk you through
some of the progress
in sparse nonlinear models of fluid
dynamics
in all of these cases we are going to
find models like this
x dot equals f of x where
x is a low dimensional vector that
describes
the dominant coherent patterns in these
flows
so out of the very complex millions or
billions of degrees of freedom you would
need to simulate
these on a computer we're going to
extract the three or four or five
most important coherent structures in x
and f is going to be the dynamics that
describe how those coherent structures
evolve and interact in time and that's
going to be a sparse
non-linear dynamical systems model so
that's what we're going to do today and
i'm going to jump right in
so i want to acknowledge that this has
been work with lots of great
colleagues co-authors collaborators
great students in postdocs on this so
the sparse non-linear modeling work
started out with nathan kutz and josh
proctor where we developed lots of the
mathematical theory
and extensions of the algorithm and then
we've extended this to many many fluid
systems with baron nowak
uh jc louiseau from paris tech george
regas from
imperial uh college and i want to also
acknowledge
uh the army and the air force funded um
most of this work so uh and all of this
was done
by our excellent uh students and
post-docs on these projects
okay good uh so i want to start off i'm
gonna start off on my soapbox here
this is uh kind of my entry point when i
talk about machine learning so many of
you have heard this before if you listen
uh in and you've seen some of my talks
there is a need for interpretable
and generalizable machine learning
methods
so instead of you know we know that
neural networks are super powerful
but they're kind of opaque they're black
box so
we want machine learning models that are
more interpretable and generalizable
and instead of defining these i'm just
going to make enemies if i try to define
these things
i'm going to give you an analogy okay so
in my mind
the quintessential interpretable
generalizable model
is f equals m a so it's interpretable
because it has three terms f m and a
they have units
i can write down these equations for a
particular system of interest and
analyze them and we can discuss
what those terms mean it's interpretable
it's generalizable in the sense
that newton can learn f equals ma from
apples falling on earth
or so the story goes and that same model
is valid when we design space missions
to land humans on the moon
okay that is a generalizable model now i
have no
doubt that if i had movies of apples
falling
i could train a deep neural network to
make another movie of an apple falling
but that would not be useful to land
humans on the moon
it wouldn't be generalizable in this way
this is the kind
of model that we want in engineering
sciences in
fluids especially because so many of our
applications of fluids are safety
critical
like flight and we can't afford to not
understand
our model and we can't afford for it not
to work in a regime where we didn't
expect
it to be and this is not just newton
this idea
of of kind of mathematical modeling
being as simple as possible but not
simpler
is one of the cornerstones of
mathematical physics
einstein observed this this was observed
by aristotle 2000 years earlier
akam pareto you name it great minds
have been you know adhering to this
principle of parsimony or simplicity
to get these kinds of models in physics
and so what that means for us today
mathematically how we're going to use
this in fluid dynamics
is we are going to build low dimensional
models models in terms of only the few
variables that matter
the coherent patterns in the flow we're
going to extract those low dimensional
representations
and we're going to build sparse dynamics
models for how those low dimensional
patterns evolve in time together okay
and low dimensional and sparse are the
two mathematical ingredients that are
going to give us interpretable
and generalizable models in fluids so
sparse models
on a low dimensional state vector so
fast forward 300 years
and in the modern era we see a great
analog of this in the chaotic thermal
convection problem the rayleigh bernard
convection
so this is a very cool fluids problem
where you have a hot plate on the bottom
and a cold plate on top
this is kind of a model for how the
atmosphere
convects when the sun hits the planes
and the air starts to warm up
and cause these large convection cells
and
this fluid flow equation
is what motivated lorentz in 1963
to develop the famous lorentz model
now i'll point out i've added the names
feder and hamilton so this is linda
feder
and margaret hamilton they were his
graduate students who
helped him run these super computer
simulations to generate the data he used
to build his model so i think it's
important to remember their contribution
that's the margaret hamilton of nasa
fame so she went on to do many many
great things
and what lorentz was able to do was take
this very complex fluid flow field
and distill it down into these three
equations you see on the right
and you'll notice that this has exactly
this the low dimensional
and sparse nature that we talked about
before so it's low dimensional
in the sense that lorenz is
characterizing the system with three
variables
x y and z that describe three
spatial modes that you can add up to
approximate this flow field
and those modes were posited earlier by
saltzman at yale
and it's sparse in the sense that on the
right hand side out of all of the
possible
things that could be in the dynamics
there's only seven terms
okay so it's sparse the interactions of
x y and z
are simple and there's key mechanisms
where they interact
through sigma y and minus sigma x and
things like that
so that's going to be kind of this key
theme is building these
low dimensional sparse models and we're
going to do this
in an automated way so what i'm going to
show you today is how we are
automating what lorenz did in 1963
for more complex flows today with
machine learning and with data
okay so this is the sparse
identification of nonlinear dynamics
algorithm or
cindy this is the the 2016 paper i was
talking
about uh with nathan kutz and josh
proctor
and i'm going to walk you through this
on the laurent system
so imagine that we have the laurent
system
and i'm simulating data but all i have
access to
is the data i don't have access to the
equations so i measure
x y and z in time so i've got a time
series of these measurements and i
compute x dot y dot and z dot they're
time derivatives
so i don't know the equations but i do
have data now the simplest thing you
might think of to do
is to build a linear regression model a
best fit model
that tries to fit x dot y dot and z dot
in terms of a linear model
a times x y and z this is exactly what
dynamic mode decomposition or dmd does
now we know that a dmd model this is a
three by three linear model
with a single fixed point at the origin
there's no way it can capture this rich
complexity of the lorette system with
multiple
fixed points unstable periodic orbits
and chaos
so instead what we do is we augment
the right hand side with more candidate
terms
in the in the dynamics so instead of
just linear terms x y and z
we add x squared and x y y squared y z
all the way up to in this case fifth
order polynomials
z to the fifth and all of these gray
columns i can actually build those
from the data i collected in x y and z
and now the trick is
we're trying to find the fewest columns
remember we want
sparse models the fewest columns of
theta
that add up to equal x dot that add up
to equal y dot
and then add up to equal z dot and when
you do this
you uncover it turns out that the fewest
columns that add up to equal x dot y dot
and z dot
highlight the original terms that were
in the dynamics that actually generated
this data
now this is non-linear system id we're
generating these models directly from
our data
even though we've never seen the
equations before so
the sparse optimization if you had asked
me 20 years ago
if this is possible i would have said no
this is a brute force combinatorial
search
but it turns out that now this is uh
pretty much a commodity algorithm in
statistics
to find these sparse linear combinations
so there's dozens of algorithms to
compute these things
and to find these sparse representations
uh if you build your
your library correctly now i'll point
out in this case
we assumed that we knew the right
measurement variables x y and z
and that's a huge assumption that i'll
come back to later
okay good if you're interested in trying
this we have open source
software called pi cindy in python and
you can download this on the github and
read about it in the journal of open
source software
good so we don't just have to build
ordinary differential equation models
and here we're going to start thinking
about fluids again
we can build partial differential
equation models so this is a great work
by sam rudy who is a phd student working
with nathan and me
where he collected full spatial temporal
flow fields for the fluid flow past a
cylinder
and instead of building just an ordinary
differential equation problem
he builds a library of partial
derivatives uh
and and nonlinear products of partial
derivatives and when he applies the same
cindy sparse regression procedure you
essentially find
the uh the sparsest model that's
consistent with the data
are the navy or stokes equations here
and you'll notice that these pink terms
are the one over reynolds number they're
within one percent of the true value
so pretty remarkable just from data by
applying the sparse regression you learn
the navy or stokes equations using
sparse regression
now because the spatial temporal data is
so rich there's so much of it
we can dramatically subsample the data
we can measure
at a few random locations in space and
time
and even on that sparse subsample data
we can still identify the same navy or
stokes dynamics
so this is pretty cool okay good
now i told you earlier that we assumed
that we knew the right coordinates x y
and z for lorenz
so there was some really important work
by kathleen champion
this was also when she was doing her phd
with nathan and me
where she essentially combined
the idea of a deep autoencoder network
from machine learning
and our sparse cindy models that i was
just showing you
and so the autoencoder learns a
coordinate transformation
where your dynamics becomes sparse in
the latent variable z
and so this is a simultaneous discovery
of coordinates
and of sparse dynamics so
really cool work here and kathleen
actually has a great video lecture on
this
uh that i'll link below so you can you
know read all about this
and and see her her lecture okay good
uh so now i really want to dive into how
we're using this in the field of fluid
mechanics okay so i'm going to go
through vignettes
of how we're doing sparse nonlinear
modeling
to get reduced-order models of complex
fluid flows
so this reduced order modeling paradigm
again i'm going to walk you through what
we started doing
in our original 2016 paper and build
from there
so this is our simple low reynolds
number flow past a cylinder this is a
canonical example of vortex shedding
and bear noack and collaborators in this
famous 2003 jfm paper
told us the right coordinate system the
right low dimensional variables
to measure this this flow in so the
first two proper orthogonal
decomposition modes or singular value
decomposition modes and this third shift
mode
which is the unstable steady state minus
the mean flow
and if you model if you measure the the
flow past a cylinder in these three
coordinates
you can write down a very simple
non-linear quadratic model here in blue
that gives rise to the transient and
steady state behavior of this system
this is a famous paper and it was famous
because
it wrote down such a simple model for
this flow
uh using kind of simple arguments
and this dynamical system in blue gives
rise to a slow
manifold and it's very kind of
interpretable
sparse and low dimensional and so this
is going to be the example we're going
to warm up and try
cindy on to get a sparse model so we
are going to measure this system in
those same three coordinates and we're
going to take
x y and z and feed those into our cindy
algorithm
and when we do that we uncover a model
that has essentially the same terms as
the noack model
and it has the same slow manifold our
identified system has the slow parabolic
manifold
and it captures the same transient and
steady state dynamics
as the original noack model so this is
pretty cool we were really excited when
we saw this
very soon after putting this paper on
the archive i got an email from
john christophe lazo he was at kth at
the time now he's at paris tech
and he had two key innovations that
really upped our game in modeling fluids
with cindy
so the first observation is that when we
do this sparse cindy regression
we're not taking into account any
background knowledge about our flow
but jc knows that incompressible navy or
stokes equations conserve
energy and he says they conserve energy
we know how they conserve energy through
these skew-symmetric quadratic
non-linearities
and so in our sparse regression
you can essentially add constraint
equations so that the terms
the quadratic terms have to be skew
symmetric
and by doing so we make it so that our
models our sparse models conserve
energy by construction so that
immediately
improves the stability and the learning
rate of our models
the second thing he did and this is i
think really important
is include higher order non-linearities
into the model
so in our original model we had
quadratic non-linearities
because we wanted to match bear noak's
model and we knew that the navy or
stokes equations had quadratic
non-linearities
but when you allow yourself to have
higher order terms cubic quintic septic
nonic so
third fifth seventh ninth order terms
you essentially are accounting
for very low energy modes that we've
truncated or neglected
and how they affect the large energetic
modes we are trying to model
so by adding cubic and fifth and seventh
order terms
to these x and y equations we
essentially account for these
higher frequency mode pairs that we have
neglected
these low energy but high frequency mode
pairs
and so what you get are much more
accurate models
and it's in some sense a rudimentary
closure model
for this very simple laminar flow so i
want to be careful
in calling this a closure model because
this is not turbulent
but it is kind of closing the truncated
scales and how they affect the large
energy scales
so let's see how this works on the
cylinder flow and on the cavity flow two
of my favorite examples
what we see here in the middle column is
kind of our benchmark
a delta is a quantity that's essentially
a prax
a proxy for the drag so this is a
quantity of interest we want to model
in the system and the white curve is the
ground truth from a direct numerical
simulation
so when we start off the simulation the
drag rises and it goes to some steady
state value
and in yellow and in blue these are the
industry standard
state-of-the-art pod galarkin models
we basically take the proper orthogonal
decomposition
and we glur can project the
navier-stokes equations onto either
three modes or seven modes
so we see that these models and these
are the kinds of models baron noack was
building
in that 2003 paper so we see that these
are qualitatively
pretty they capture the right features
but quantitatively they're off they have
the wrong rise time
they overshoot and they have steady
state error
whereas when we introduce our cindy
models with either cubic non-linearities
or constraints
built in we almost perfectly capture
both qualitatively and quantitatively
the dynamics
now here's a really important point i
want to make because these cindy models
are
sparse it's literally a sparse
differential equation with as few terms
as possible
it is interpretable jc and i can
write down this equation and go get a
coffee in paris
and and manipulate and analyze that
equation and that's exactly what he did
and he wrote down this differential
equation from the cindy model for
cylinder flow
and showed that this system is
essentially a spring mass
damper with a non-linear damping term or
a van der pol oscillator
and this is to date the simplest and the
most accurate model of the cylinder flow
that i have seen on on record because of
sparsity because of the sparse
regression
okay good now we have extended this to
more complex flows like this
fluidic pinball that has three cylinders
and has much more broadband uh behavior
in the wake
and importantly we don't need the full
flow field
or someone to tell us what coordinates
to measure this system in
we can build our sparse models directly
from
lift and drag measurements of these
three cylinders so those are kind of
obvious measurements you would take
you don't need the full wake velocity
field measurements
you just need six measurements of the
lift and drag on each
cylinder and you can build these very
very accurate cindy models
that match the dns the direct numerical
simulation
very faithfully so i think this is super
cool
this accounts for some of the issues of
um
you know proper orthogonal decomposition
often
is is going to fail if you change the
flow velocity or i change the geometry
or i move the bodies
but building models directly in lift and
drag coordinates
is really nice because those are
intrinsic and those mean the same thing
even when my flow velocity changes even
when my geometry changes
okay good so now we're going to go on to
some more complex
examples so i'm going to go back to the
chaotic thermal convection rayleigh
bernard
and i want to highlight this really cool
work by jc that he put out last year in
tcfd
where he was analyzing this chaotic
thermosyphon
so it's basically a hula hoop or an
annular region that's heated from below
and cooled from above and it creates and
sets up this
thermal convection cycle that's chaotic
similar to the rayleigh bernard
convection
and so what jc was able to do by
extracting modes automatically
through dynamic mode decomposition and
modeling the evolution of those modes in
time with cindy
he was able to show that this chaotic
thermosyphon flow
is structurally the same as the laurent
63 model
for rayleigh bernard convection for a
completely different geometry
and so this is a really really cool
result very nice paper
kind of showing that lorenz is even more
general than we thought
to these other flows and that you can
automatically model them
using these techniques so that model was
not written down for this
before jc and so this is a real new
scientific
discovery very cool we've been working
on other convection problems so this is
work by ife guan and igor novosilov
ife was a phd student working with igor
he's now a postdoc at rice
and he was working on this great electro
convection problem
so electro convection is a little bit
more complicated than standard rayleigh
bernard
because it has a three-way coupling
between the fluid flow
the charge density and the electric
field which sets up these rich
kind of chaotic convection patterns
and so what we did here is started
trying to apply these
automated sparse modeling procedures to
get low order models
of this chaotic electro convection so we
collect spatial temporal data in time
in space and time we extract the key
modes the low dimensional features the
energetic coherent structures that
matter
using proper orthogonal decomposition
and then we look at how the amplitudes
of those pod modes evolve in time
so a1 is the amplitude of the first mode
a2 is the amplitude of the second mode
and so on
and these are how the mode amplitudes
evolve with respect to each other
in time and we observed we noticed
that this flow has deep deep symmetries
there is an incredible symmetry when you
look at these mode coefficients of how
the energy is being transferred
through these modes and so we were able
to
learn those symmetries to write them
down and to enforce them in our cindy
model
so this is using that that same
technique john christophe lazo taught us
we can now add those symmetry
constraints directly into our cindy
model
so we get a non-linear model that it
satisfies those symmetries by
construction
and we get this sparse model that has
the same skeletal
kind of structural dynamics it misses
some of the details
but it captures the big features of this
flow
very nicely using this and we can get
the flow fields
by adding up these pod modes in these a1
a2 a3 combination
so let's zoom in a little more and look
at these symmetries so this is the phase
portrait
of those pod amplitudes and we can write
down these five symmetries that we
observe in the system it's invariant
uh to switching the sign of a2 or
switching the sign of a3
and so on and so forth there's these
invariants in the in the data
and so what that means is that when we
write down our cindy library the library
of possible nonlinear terms and the
dynamics
a lot of them immediately have to be
zero we've blacked out a lot of these
terms that
can't be active with these symmetries
being observed
and even more than that there are other
conditions like you know this sigma
2 has to be the opposite of this sigma 2
and so on and so forth there are these
kind of additional constraints on the
cindy library
that have to be true based on these
symmetries
and so when we enforce those in our
cindy regression
we can get away with less data because
there's less coefficients we're trying
to identify
and we get more stable more accurate
models
in this case again we get this model
here that has the right structure
of the of the data now it doesn't
capture every small feature there are
these little loops here we're not
capturing
but we get a lot of the features of the
data and kind of this chaotic
uh electro convection so very promising
that you can scale this up to pretty
sophisticated systems again
we didn't have reduced order models for
this when we started this is a new model
and you can analyze this kind of how
lorentz analyzed the 63 model
so another great example this is work by
alan captain auglu who's a phd student
working with me
on plasma physics so he has
a three-dimensional simulation of a
spherimack fusion reactor here
that is matched to experiments and
he has from this simulation data of this
3d system
extracted again the low dimensional
features we care about using pod
and he had to cook up his own
dimensional pod
since you know your magnetic field and
your velocity field have different units
so that we had to can make a conversion
so they can speak the same language and
then in this coordinate system you're
able to build a sparse nonlinear model
that satisfies the constraints of the pd
of the
mhd equations and down here you see that
our reduced order model our
sparse nonlinear model captures the
structural dynamics
of this spheromac fusion reactor
very very accurately so this is very
promising we're starting to add things
like injector dynamics and control
so that we can use these reduced order
models for online
control of experiments hopefully so
that's where this is going
is these models are so fast and so
efficient and they seem to be pretty
accurate
maybe we can use this for something like
model predictive control down the road
okay good so um
i'm just going to keep going because i
love this stuff and we've got more
i've been kind of blown away with the
progress in the last few years if you
had asked me two years ago
if some of these flows were possible to
analyze with cindy i would have said
probably not but with great students and
great collaborators we've started
opening up
a lot of these problems and complexities
so one of the ones i'm really excited
about this is new work
by jared callahan a great phd student of
mine
and jc lazo that the archive paper
should be coming out very soon
where we're analyzing more complex
higher dimensional systems
like this shear driven cavity that has
if you did the proper orthogonal
decomposition you would find that there
might be a couple dozen
modes that are energetic and important
and so
when they analyze this flow uh of course
you have the shear layer instability
and you have the inner cavity modes like
this is classical theory we know that
these
are dominant kind of mode structures
that give rise to these dynamics but in
a purely data driven fashion again when
we look at the mode amplitudes
versus each other in time so a1 versus
a2 a2 versus a3 and so on
you see this incredibly rich correlated
structure here
that's highly indicative of nonlinear
dynamics
and so by identifying the two driving
mode pairs
uh jared and jc were able to build this
extremely
simple cindy model up to fifth order
that almost perfectly captures the
dynamics of the full
nonlinear simulation and if we zoom in
we can look at the power spectrum of the
log of the energy
and you know we have power peaks from
the cavity mode and the shear layer mode
we have power peaks from kind of these
harmonics the second harmonic the
non-linear crosstalk
and higher order harmonics and our cindy
model
almost perfectly captures all of them
this
blew me away when i saw this absolute
beautiful agreement of
many many modes all the way up to like
a19 in this case that's the 19th pod
mode
so we're capturing the full spectrum
of this cavity again with a two state
cindy model and then kind of how they
impact these higher
modes very cool you can read about this
soon on the archive
and another thing kind of i'm really
excited about
that i wouldn't have thought is possible
a couple of years ago
is extending this to full-blown
turbulent systems
so turbulence is hard because you have
coherent structures
but they're forced by multi-scale
structures
that you don't want to model or or
necessarily kind of keep track of
and so this is worked by jared jc and
george regis
where we essentially are modeling the
longivian dynamics
of turbulent fluid flows so here we have
x dot equals f of x that's our original
cindy model for the coherent structures
plus sigma w this is
a noise term a colored noise term that
forces our dynamics stochastically and
so what we're doing here is we're
simultaneously identifying the sparse
nonlinear dynamics of the coherent
structures
and the color noise forcing of all of
those
small scale turbulence fluctuations that
are forcing the system
this is closely related to the focker
planck equation
which describes the evolution of
distributions or ensembles of
trajectories
but we're taking the launch of an
approach and i'll point out we're
building on
prior work by bona sega and clementi and
others
that extended cindy to longivin systems
for molecular dynamics
so we've extended it to higher
dimensional fluid systems
and i'm not going to jump into all of
the details here because it's a little
bit involved
but the basic idea is that we're
parametrizing
our nonlinear dynamics and our noise
just like in cindy
and then we're finding sparse non-linear
models
by fitting the data by essentially
building distributions
and by adjoint optimization trying to
find sparse
c vectors that model these nonlinear
dynamics and noise forcing
and in all of the cases we've looked at
from simple toy examples
to fully turbulent wake data from
experiments we get very simple
structural models for the coherent
structures
and a very simple representation of the
colored noise forcing
from the subscale turbulent fluctuations
that we're not modeling
or we're not keeping track of and just
to illustrate this on
the cavity flow this again is the full
direct numerical simulation
and down here this is our longivin
reduced order model
so you can see that we're capturing kind
of the key dynamics of these pod modes
these kind of figure eight dynamics but
we're also getting the spread
of the dynamics because we're accounting
for this noise forcing
that broadens uh those trajectories
very very cool and it seems to work on
this fairly turbulent
uh sorry not not this but on really
turbulent data like wake
uh wake data from from experiments
okay good um so i think the last thing i
want to show you i've shown you a lot
this is the whirlwind tour of sparse
non-linear modeling of fluids
the last thing i want to show you is
pretty new and it's a little bit of a
different take on sparse modeling again
with jared callahan
um uh james koch nathan kutz and bing
brunton
and this is sparse modeling of
terms in equations uh to see which terms
balance each other at what locations of
space and time
so there's this idea of dominant balance
in physics
where even if you have a very complex
equation like the full 3d navy or stokes
equations
maybe at a place a location in space
only a few of those terms are active and
large and are kind of balancing each
other out
while most of the other terms are small
so this is the idea of dominant balance
and it's the foundation of asymptotic
analysis and asymptotic expansions
most of the applied math departments in
the country grew
up out of this idea of asymptotics and
dominant balance in physics where you
could
write down solutions on pen and paper by
hand before computers
by simplifying the equations to a few
key terms that are interacting
and what jared's going to do on this
johns hopkins
turbulent boundary layer is automate
this dominant balance procedure with
machine learning
and sparse non-linear modeling so
if you take the reynolds average navy or
stokes equations the rand's equations
here
you see that there are
in two dimensions there are six terms
and for each of those terms
you can essentially plot what that
term's magnitude is at every point in
space
so this is one term in my equation at
every location in space on the boundary
layer
and you can plot all six of those
equation terms like this
so this is essentially an equation space
representation
so now for every point i can take that
point and i can plot it in a six
dimensional equation space
in all of these six coordinate axes
and that's exactly what jared did so
this is just two slices in equation
space of all of those points
and you'll see that the data appears to
live on these kind of subspaces or
clusters so jared applies relatively
simple
machine learning clustering in this case
gaussian mixture models
to find which clusters are active how
the data clusters
and i'm only showing you a couple slices
so there's other dimensions where the
other terms cluster
and again dominant balance is about
trying to figure out which
terms are small almost zero and which
terms are big and are balancing each
other
so what we're going to try to do for
example this red
this red set of points here this red
cluster this
term is approximately zero and these two
terms are in a balance
so we're also going to apply sparse
subspace identification or sparse pca
to find which terms are active
approximately active and which terms are
approximately zero for each of these
five clusters and so again these black
squares are the terms that are
approximately zero
and what's really cool is that every
point here
you can re-plot that point in space
where it was in space
and you find that these five regimes of
dominant balance correspond to five
classical regimes from from the boundary
layer
so we recover the viscous sublayer the
inertial subway layer
the transitional region purely in an
automated data-driven fashion
so this is phenomenal this allows us to
actually uncover these dominant balance
regimes
purely from data with relatively simple
sparse modeling
right we're trying to find the sparsest
combination of terms that are active
in these clusters and again this
ca recapitulates classic boundary layer
theory
that was hard fought over the last
hundred years by many many smart people
so we've looked at this for the boundary
layer i just showed you
uh we've looked at this for the super
continuum laser this
high energy optical pulse propagation
this is a really cool example because
this is a very non-linear system this is
non-linear wave physics
but it turns out when you do this
dominant balance the only region in the
xt diagram where nonlinear terms are
active
is in this tiny thin blue layer here
so all of the nonlinearity is actually
very localized
in this in this problem we've applied
this to geophysical flows like the flow
in the gulf of mexico from the hicom
data
and we've relearned kind of the classic
geostrophic balances
and we're hoping to learn new balance
laws new almost invariances in the flow
that might have been missed by by humans
that might have been too complicated to
write down
we're applying this to neuroscience data
and the real promise here
is to apply this to fields where we
don't know the answer where we don't
know
about the transitional region and the
inertial sub layer problems like
neuroscience where we can learn
new dominant balance laws and simplified
physics
in different regions of space and time
so i'm super super excited about that
and i hope you are too i hope you use uh
this for your own problems i hope you
extend the method and you know apply
this to new problems to discover new
models that we didn't have before
so i'm super excited about where this is
and i'm looking forward to making
another video
in five years uh you know what sparse
non-linear models we have
you know in 2025 or 2026. all right
thank you